hello everyone and welcome to day three
of the Lindo rossabi rapid challenge
which means this is the final match of
the clash between Hikaru and dubov first
match was won by Hikaru second module
and now the this is the final one and
who wins this one wins the entire event
so without further ado let's check it
out he car with the white pieces again
goes for afor and above again goes for
the Sicilian defense so c5 Knight of 3/9
to c6 and now everyone was thinking
whether he car will go for the alop and
once again or will he try better up to
be 5 or whatnot but he continues with
nice to see 3 same as on day two we have
g6 by dubov and now d4 now opening up in
the center seek actress Knight
characters and Bishop to g7 so again
going for the 40 accelerator dragon set
up with Bishop to e3 and the knight to
f6
we have Bishop the c4
castles by du Bois and Bishop to b3
that's a standard retreat square for the
bishop we looked at 8 and now well there
are a couple of very popular moves here
but Knight captures and c6 is a very
rare move it's not a new move but much
rarer than the other moves and this was
what he called prepared for this game so
d characters on c6 it's a principle to
capture towards the center but then you
immediately allow a 5 F 4 and so on and
black will have a lot of problems
developing so here D characters and c6
instead and of course Google now offers
a queen trade but Queen character sandy
8 and Queen to have three are known
moves in the position however Hikaru
prepared h3 and it is already as a move
tendered we have a completely new game
the idea is that white is playing
against Blacks that are a light square
Bishop so all these squares are now not
available for the Bishop to be developed
okay you could develop a t6 but then
white could just capture and really mess
up your pawn structure so here do both
took some time to consider whether it
whether to trade and go some like E 5 or
I had to go Queen to c7 which he goes
for he decides not to trade Queens and
he called just goes for f4 so again
dubov has to decide how to properly how
to properly castle here
so now he car stops 'if I've but you
could go for some like East eggs but
then again you will have problems
developing your light-square bishop so
instead the dubov goes for b5 he wants
to play b4 and put pressure on the e4
pawn he Carl goes e5 and now a double
width with a very nice trick b4 point is
that you don't really get two pieces for
one piece because if you capture the
nighted then do buffs plan was the
capture with the pawn and I open up the
attack towards the bishop and also the
night is still under attack so after
some moves you're gonna play captures
captures little Bishop e6 cut off the
King from castling kingside and the disc
King is looking pretty awful here you
could Castle queenside but the Queen
side is already busted so not much going
on there
so after before Nakamoto goes Knights
the a4 and now Knight to d5 you have to
move your night somewhere the bishop is
under attack and Queen to f3 not trying
to save the bishop air but rather just
making room for the King to be able to
Castle queenside so Knight captures an
e3 Google eliminates the bishop he now
is the only person with the bishop pair
with queen characters on e3
and now a5 so adding more defense to the
d4 pawn also can now come to a6 which is
which is a nice diagonal for the bishop
so queenside castle by nakamura and now
Nakamura's idea is that well he has a
very nice bishop on this diagonal the
knight isn't all that impressive here
but black doesn't have a b or a deep on
so you could always put this Knight to
c5 and what you want to do here is place
and like h4 h5 bust open the position
and hopefully checkmate the black king
so DuBose the move is of course Queen to
a7 he wants the trade Queens and he call
pretty much blitzed out everything here
he had at this position he had some 16
minutes on the clock whereas dubov had 6
so do we really burning his time and now
Hikaru has to make a decision whether he
wants to trade Queens right away maybe
he wants to play queen c5 Queen b6 and
maybe also as a ways of improving the
position of the night if black is really
eager to trade maybe Queens you want to
activate the rook maybe avoid the Queen
trade altogether with Queen f3 Queen g3
so a lot of possibilities here however
Hikaru
for Quinta efore it's a very nice
central square for the Queen
so again has to be very careful for
example if you try something like h5 to
prevent White's expansion here you could
run into Queen captures and g6 because
the F pawn is pinned so you have to be
careful
however this allows dooble to develop
with Bishop to five one of the reasons
why Queen Queen t4 might not be the best
square for the Queen and I was gonna
mention this I didn't know if it was all
that relevant like all the engines were
were in favor of just trading the Queen
and playing the same game saying it was
superior to white but in a rapid game as
a human you will you kind of want to
keep the Queens on the board try try and
attack and and checkmate your opponent's
king so Queen to see for now putting
pressure on the f7 point as well as the
c6 pawn although it's a very very
unlikely that you're interested in
capturing this token of the C file for
the rooks but now Du Bois gets Queen to
eat sorry
yeah Du Bois gets Queen - III check-in
king can be won and now push back that
a6 again putting pressure on the Queen
offering the c6 pawn but then of course
you just get the subchapters here and
then you open up the C file for for
blacks rooks not something you want to
do so Queen to d4 only now there's not
come we're all for a Queen trade and the
dubov except so we have characters
captures and now rook a to d8 so if you
look at this position and the one where
you had the opportunity of trading
Queens and a7 or maybe just going Queen
here to activate the night it would be
it would be preferable to this and now
nakamora doesn't go for this captures
captures and Bishop captures on e6 to
ruin White's pawn structure followed by
95 for example going after this point he
doesn't want to allow gube of any
counter play along the d file and
getting group to d2 would be very active
and also dubu will have some g5 ideas in
the future challenging the e5 pawn yeah
and so on so here nakamura just doubles
up on the d file and now do both trades
rook captures with rook captures and the
best back to c8 now do bob doesn't allow
this trade on e6 and he wants to play a
six at some point nights the b6 by
nakamura now again putting pressure on
this bishop here but now c5 also c4
might be and
an important resource in the future and
now Nakamura again goes back with rook
to d1 there was the idea of rook to c4
which wins the c5 pawn
however again and Nakamura doesn't want
to allow above counter play along the D
file now you're threatening checkmate
and well you you kind of don't want to
go something like King to see one then
ideas like then ideas like just the
Bishop to e6 become possible and well
you're gonna capture on b3 a ruined
white pawn structure
it doesn't seem to be worth upon and if
you go for something like a3 still
Bishop to e6 will result in the same
thing like say rook captures on c5 in
you could capture right away you could
capture here or always always will
for example captures captures be
captures an a3 and now again rook to be
to do but we'll get a lot of activity
for his rook however white should be
better he is up some points but this is
a weak point you're gonna play g5 this
we're gonna be a weak pawn so it's hard
to say but rook to c4 definitely an idea
here for white do to look for advantage
however Nakamura goes back with rook to
d2 and here Du Bois goes g5 now he wants
the weak and the e5 pawn and and capture
that that guy and the situation on the
clock is nine minutes Nakamura and only
three minutes to do both so again
burning his time but Nakamura catching
up so here we have looked back to d5 by
Nakamura and now he kind of admits that
he lost a valuable temple there and now
he again goes for the c5 pawn but now
black got this g5 move included so G
captures an f4 rook captures on c5 and
now the very nice tactical shot f3 here
dubov just weakens the h3 pawn and you
don't have time to go for the bishop
because then just be capture some g2
yeah we'll win the game so G CalPERS on
f3
Bishop captures on h3 and now rook
captures on a5 but now rook to b8 and
well nakamura played the entire game
trying to prevent Du Bois from gaining
the D file but to do with Indian gains
that not only the file but also a
superior superior position so a Nakamura
will fight where he is
August he has three to one advantage and
on the queenside so he pushes a four
creates a passed pawn be characters we
have be characters now another past a
pawn is created and now II six do both
has to decide whether to go east six or
start pushing the H pawn right away
however he wants to take away the d5
square away from the white knight and
also prevent white from going east six
at any point so we have kinked King to a
tomb also if this diagonal sometimes
opens up you don't want to meet rook to
d1 followed by rook to e1 checkmate so
our King here will be somewhat safer and
only now debuff starts pushing the pawn
with h5 and now rook to a for leaving
the d5 pawn undefended but you have to
activate the rook somehow and you will
not be able to activate it along the
fifth rank so do both captures it and
now comes work the e4 attacking that
Bishop on e5 however this move loses the
game and it's a very it's a very well
it's a very interesting idea how it
loses so feel free to pause the video
and try to figure out how it loses while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on perfectly utilizing
the bishop pair and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's Bishop
to g3 and the point behind Bishop to g3
is a very simple whatever white plays on
the next move doesn't really matter you
start pushing the pawn or whatever just
Bishop the g2 and that's pretty much it
after Bishop the g2 there is there is no
stopping this H for the the two bishops
are controlling all four squares that
the pawn needs to be well they're
basically just exactly escorting the
pond on the board so it's completely
winning for black and it's something you
might remember for your own games for
example if you have the two bishops you
just put them like this the guard these
four squares and you push the pawn might
come in handy
however Du Bois went Bishop to f6
probably with the idea of getting the
Bishop to g2 and getting the same idea
here however now Hikaru does get some
counter play Hikaru goes back with the
rook rook to e1 of course you don't want
to me to rook to d1 followed by rook to
a-1 and now h4 do
just continues pushing the pawn we rook
the g1 check King to f8 in the now
Knight to c4 are getting the knight back
into the game we have the ship to f5 now
and here comes rook to h1 keeping around
at H pawn
however rooked the d4 and now Nakamura
Nakamura has to try something he played
it plays nice to e3 attacking the bishop
here but butcher back to g6 so although
the position is still better for black
at these two bishops are now here
instead of being here where they would
simply prevent the rook from ever
reaching the h1 and the point would have
already won the game but ok now Nakamura
starts pushing his passport with a 4 we
have Bishop to h5 going after the f3
pawn and Nakamura doesn't bother
defending the pawn he just continues
pushing his own past a pawn we have
Bishop captures an f3 and now comes Luke
to f1 attacking the bishop here and the
rook to f4 duo just defends it and the
nakamura again goes for the pawn Porsche
with a 6 and the situation the clock is
30 SEC 3 3 minutes Nakamura in 30
seconds do both so do both very very
long time and well a 7 a 8 is coming so
duo finds the the absolute best Bishop
to d4 you cannot you you might think ok
well my Bishop is guarding the 8 square
but if you allow a 7 then real captures
will be will be a huge problem and if
you move with the Bishop you lose the
rook
so that's of d4 absolutely the best move
the only move that wins for Du Bois
attacks the night covers the a1 square
covers the h7 square ideas like well now
if the knight moves for example let's
say try Knights to g2 to get the night
away rook the f5 is deadly as you're
still guarding this rook to a5 will be
will be immediate death for white so
after this trip to d4 nakamura tried
rook to e1 to defend the night but now
the book just like rook to e4 and now
there is no saving this night whatever
you play loses the game a 7 is still
guarded by the bishops oh nothing
nothing happening there and of course
very important the bishop still covers
h1 which is the Queen
so incredibly impressive game by both of
them and Nakamura I did not go for that
c5 pawn in the right moment and he
didn't he didn't trade Queens and e8
which was also a possibility he also
didn't capture an e6 that the mess of do
was construction so there were a lot of
micro decisions that just led to do was
a big advantage and double of course
took advantage of that but I think he
car was mostly just playing very quickly
he he was trying to put time pressure on
do both but do both it didn't seem to
mind or the time pressure and in the end
he just prevailed so that's the second
game dubov takes the lead in the match
and now Nakamura has to win at least one
game from the next two to get back into
the match and maybe maybe force
Armageddon sure like I said I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Carl Ivor unless we're scum TV Dale
Bowden Alexandre Cree and Mathis
financial financial corporate
corporation for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Endora
Sabu rapid challenge until it finishes
and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever 170
in the chest world so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day